okay I think that as you're progressing
to be as you're progressing to be a
better human being I find that your
brother is regressing did he tell you
about what happened over the weekend no
I would like to know know what is your
gonna say what happened this does anyone
know what happened over the weekend okay
okay what are you gonna say before we
even get into might stop the biggest
thing all right well I'm stopping you
what that that has no business in in
this pocket I feel like it's my right to
tell this story it's my story to tell
guess why what you girls cuz I didn't
[ __ ] put your poop in a doggie bag
didn't I whoa it's my story now as if I
have to do the cleanup it's my story to
tell
tell us Bobby your story so I get a
phone call I get a phone call he's
coming home from from Warner Brothers
and I got a frantic phone call he's like
that's not something so bad gyrase for
yeah he went to terrace which is great
food but oh no there's a new one on the
way and I get a phone call he's like
babe something really bad just happened
in my head the first thing is like oh my
god he's finally run over somebody and
like that's what I could just drive it
yeah because he's a wild dude his
drivings insane yeah so then I was like
[ __ ] what happened and he's like I need
help I'm downstairs in the garage and
there's poo everywhere and I'm like how
is there poo everywhere it turns out
that he was on the freeway enroute to
come home
stuck in traffic couldn't make it out of
the exit pulled over into the side of
the freeway climbed over into the
backseat and took [ __ ] in the backseat
because his merchandise idiot that's
some kind of freely or highly he stopped
either but he did it on a paper plate at
least he did it right on the scene
disgusting man
and then he comes he comes running need
help bro I can't tell you what happens
afterwards is a beast so he tells he
comes up and I see his butt as he's what
runs into the bathroom and it's just
diarrhea all over his pants so then I'm
thinking he couldn't even take his
[ __ ] pants off his health and then
into the car seat in a special word fine
listen to this Steve and then bad and
then I said okay fine I'll take it to
the car wash in the morning but I was
like you know what I'm not gonna do it
I'm gonna have Jenna do it because do
you know Jenna needs the money and I so
I told her you better get $500 she came
in in a hazmat suit she can't I swear to
god she came in fully suited up at the
bet but then he goes it was fifty
dollars it was fifty he said he said I
tried to I tried to clean it with a
spray as best as I could so Jenna should
be fine dry so Jenna basically had
but then that's not the worst part on
the way there on the way there Jenna
checked the backseat because she was
like something sounds really bad are you
sure that he cleaned it with spray and
she goes back there and there's two big
turds that kind of just roll have been
rolling around in the back seat it was
camouflaged into the yeah so she then
has to she then had she calls me she's
like oh my god I don't know what to do
but there's still pool rolling around
back there and so I she had to pick it
up she had to use her hand she had to
raw hand it I'm worried about his health
there's so much gonna get a cold away
there's so much meat Korean barbecue and
just I know his body I am his brother
his little brother here he's got so much
just stored meat Gogi and steak and cuz
he eats so good we need to get him like
flushed out okay let me tell you my
point of view okay okay
so when told you told me to clean the
car I went down there alright I cleaned
the drivers seat because when I climbed
back and oh [ __ ] all over drivers there
yeah and when I look back there right it
looked like just the back in the day
during Vietnam just like you know you
know just a war zone hmm there's [ __ ]
all over the place and I I just thought
to myself
do it and she did it Thank You Jenna but
then here's I went to the store though
that night right and the [ __ ] was still
back there the pool yeah
and the do you know we have a lot guy at
the Comedy Store mm-hmm and he walks in
the car and he goes dude it smells like
[ __ ] in here there is right and he'll
just left my car there the whole night
in one spot he had to maneuver all the
cars are on my car they wouldn't drive
it they wouldn't drive it yeah yeah so
if you want people to drive your car
that's a good way to do it I mean and
then also on top of it I'll tell you
I'll tell you my point of view on the
incident okay yeah so when I could've
wins just listen listen to what I and
what now can you listen to my point so
when I was at Terrace which is delicious
by the way now I wonder I ordered just a
chicken Tinga super nachos not enough
super nachos in a quesadilla I ate it
and I I was I left the restaurant and
then in my head I'm like oh [ __ ] I
she I order her a salad mmm right so I
ran back in I had already bought it
I could you have to sell it I said to go
they go yeah and as soon as she grabbed
him like this food ID you got to get
this to kalila because my little baby
honey is starving he's gonna put it on
me no I'm not gonna put it on you baby
honey but then when I was walking out of
the building I this is what I heard
right that wasn't even a fart that was
my stomach oh damn that was your stomach
yeah yeah
that wasn't even a fart I fought it
inside my body yeah have you ever done
that
it just yeah I've sucked I've sucked on
it yeah in my body and it a little sweat
and I was like now this is as an adult
you have these questions should I get in
the car
and just [ __ ] drive all right or
shakes go to the bathroom here yeah was
in Terry still because she ended it her
salad I would but it was also to say
this it wasn't fully like oh I can't
[ __ ] right now I just feel like growing
up
wrong for the record baby honey could
have waited I know I know for a salad I
know okay so when you pulled over no she
got it wrong okay so I'm not even on the
freeway okay I'm like kind of like where
you know where Highland is but this is
like five o'clock that's its pad right
and it won't move and all of us and I
felt a fart that's a fart nothing came
out just fine no but it was like you
know how the that was like my opening
act like my opening act was strong yeah
Boop and right then I thought the middle
act was gonna go up but no but the
headliner was there yeah yeah there's no
middle app no sharp
no it was poop and then the head stuck
out right like that
I don't know hole like that right now
solid and I go where's the middle act
yeah a couple more farts there's no
middle act right so he needs to go up
now the headliner makes me even angrier
fact that it wasn't diarrhea it means
that it wasn't that urgent it was urgent
are you out of your line it was so
urgent and let me just say this right
now did you see the back of my it was a
show this show it's just it was a
variety show oh I'm not just now right
it wasn't just and it was there was
water you mean there was like you know
mean some other things so I pull over to
a residential area and there's
construction happening on my right side
and there's you know how those gigantic
construction trash containers the
gigantic ones I pull right behind there
and I jump in the back seat I pull my
pants down and I just you know all over
okay and the beginning of it was the
solid part but the end I'm telling you
right now as Jesus as my witness it was
a liquid show yeah circus Elena okay and
I felt like killing myself it was
horrific but he still brought up my
salad with a truck full of [ __ ] in his
but he came home and there's poo
everywhere but he had a salad
unhappily dedicated ya gotta kid never
done that ever I've done all the time
I've seen me too on houses yeah on house
walls like he will actually just bend
over shoot it like point his butt at a
wall and spray she saw me do that and on
someone's like gardenias yeah yeah maybe
not
I mean his health man you know no I'm
serious yeah like are you being real
serious right now being serious so you
let me ask you something what do you
think is going on with me you think I
eat all me no veggies no hmm that's
interesting it's potato vegetable yes it
is I eat that too I'm just saying
you because you have so much money you
make a good living okay you could eat
cream everyone this thing I do okay you
thank you you you could have no crystal
you could afford eating out he could
afford eating out all the time right
mm-hmm
I don't he doesn't go to it like
Souplantation does he house snoopavision
like the healthy spine oh no it's just
not veggies cucumbers tomatoes you know
I mean veggies what i yesterday me
yesterday yes yeah so yesterday I woke
up and your little Filipino nieces will
sing with us Julianna great oh yeah
she's great and so I took her to Warner
Brothers and let's go to the smokehouses
right next to what and I had a prime rib
so good yeah right but I had fried
zucchini right fried zucchini deep fried
like that is not healthy sweetie it
totally just eliminates the outer part
is unhealthy but the inner part is
healthy no it's not you've already taken
deep frying it takes away all of the
good stuff Oh anyway then what else did
I have then we had the artichoke the
grilled artichoke that was good this is
all at the same place yeah at the same
place so I had a prime rib garlic bread
the last night I had
bossa nova I had a fried right frytss no
was a chicken like you know fried fried
with battered fries that's my concern is
you guys are doing well he's doing well
that's the only thing that could take
him down is his health
that's why I don't go out to eat with
you guys anymore so we're not going to
eat after this because I just can't we
got more we got a guess I got a text
back yeah I have an episode I have to
touch but I can't to to eat as
indulgently as him so I don't go out to
eat with him I just make my own food at
home because that shit's not healthy
could he do the in terment intermittent
fasting do you know what I was doing
every Sunday I would not eat for 24
hours ago that's his that's not his
problem because he actually won't eat
for 16 hours but in those eight hours he
eats real pure garbage like what I won't
eat twelve hours and I'll eat a fat
burger with fried egg and chili yeah
then my body goes credence traits like a
strawberry shortcake
and then I go right to sleep so that
stuff is in my body when I'm sleeping he
actually has a big meal before sleep
yeah mm-hmm it's not good guys it's not
good and you know it's very concerning
is he sleeping okay no today he slept at
like 10 o'clock in the morning
yeah the morning yeah I'd have a 10
o'clock got a call time tomorrow morning
- oh gosh
I mean yeah he self-sabotaging i-i-i-i
how do you Jesus pay on you I mean do
you what time do you go to sleep um like
1 2 to 3 that's better what are you
doing are you playing Red Dead
Redemption which I want to talk about ok
that's a great segue
what a great you're a professional all
right
[Music]